So what makes games different
from other types of apps?
It's a hard question, because there
are so many different types of games.
But here are a few of the things that
make writing games different from
writing other types of apps.
The first thing is that games
are often built around an update loop
or a game loop.
This is as opposed to an event-based
application where the application
basically sits around not doing
much of anything until the user
provides some input.
Games on the other hand,
are built around a timer that
fires 60 times a second.
When that timer fires,
it means it's time for
the game to go look at the user input,
update the state of the game world, and
then draw a new frame to the screen.
This means, games often need to
deal with pulling for user input.
Next, games often involve
a ton of custom drawing.
While you can make an Android
app using entirely off-the-shelf
user interface components, it's rare
that you can do so with the game.
You'll have to create your UI and
your game world
using either primitive shapes like
lines, rectangles and circles, or your
own custom image aspects from pixel art
all the way up to complex characters.
Many games also feature
your special effects and
animations which are a ton of fun to
make but also a lot of hard work.
There are whole fields of study
that are much more relevant to
games than other types of
apps like physics and AI.
There's also exotic input
devices to deal with,
like game pad controllers or,
more interestingly for
this class, accelerometers like
the one you've got in your phone.
Finally, my favorite
part of game development
is the fact that you get to
create a lot of objects that have
visible representations
in your game world.
Designing an elegant object
oriented app is a lot more fun,
when your objects can run around
hitting each other with swords.